welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
first look trailer for spider-man across
the spider-verse part one which already
has us asking so many questions from the
title alone but that's exactly how we'd
love it as we brace ourselves for the
sequel to the amazing 2018 spider-man
into the spider-verse a follow-up that
will show us what's next for miles
morales gwen stacy miguel o'hara and the
other infinite spider things as they
tumble through their hexagonal acid trip
i'm gonna break down this first look
frame by frame 12 of them per second for
this unique animation style to find all
the easter eggs and animation details
you missed because there are so many of
them in this and before we begin our
friends at shortbox are giving away the
first comic appearance of miles morales
to one of our lucky viewers stick around
to the end of this video to learn how to
enter to win okay so we actually open on
the comic book text box of meanwhile in
another universe which is exactly how
the 2018 film would reset itself by
introducing each new alternate
spider-man but it flickers into new
colors the way the last film would
signal the glitches as the multiverse
warped reality and briefly the word
switch to a hindi translation a signal
of one of the infinite spider-man
variants that we will see spider-man
india pavitar prabhakar so sorry from
saying that wrong this is from
earth50101 and this indian version of
the character does end up crossing over
into the spiderverse storyline in the
comics he's recruited into a spider army
by superior spiderman and if you'll
remember back in 2019 the teaser for
this film did have one mysterious spider
logo that had green white and orange
colors which are the colors of india's
flag but here we also see a spanish
translation so together these two tell
us what alternate realities we're about
to visit in this trailer mumbaitan and
the spanish-speaking miguel o'hara's
home reality so here miles is in his
bedroom listening again to post malone's
sunflower which is how i've spent the
last three years honestly i love that
song and then a portal from gwen stacy
opens and of course this is the same
exact framing the same pink black and
teal colors that we saw in the final
shot of the 2018 film but despite the
mirroring and gwen even says the same
line here that she did before
you got a minute miles
you got a minute quite a bit of time has
passed because you'll notice miles looks
older he's got a longer face and neck
his hair has grown out some and gwen now
has the tips of her hair dyed pink so
the implication is that miles has spent
many of his nights listening to
sunflower hoping that gwen might come
back to him and the clutter of his room
does remind us a lot of peter b parker's
messy room when his portal opened peter
b parker was depressed because he missed
his mary jane miles has been missing
gwen or he's just a kid and he's messy i
don't need to read too much into it but
gwen voiced by haley steinfeld who is
playing kate bishop and hawkeye at the
moment looks down at miles through a
hexagonal portal yes i know hexagons
hexagons are really just a natural
geometric formation for grid patterns
that's why the mcu uses it for the space
portal jump but in one division hexagons
were an intentional production design
choice that signaled west view took
place within wanda's reality warp hex so
it is appropriate to see this shape
being used for a gateway through
realities now among the clutter floating
in miles's room is a cup of soup and a
fork a plush toy and then this comic
book with miles on the cover true life
tales of spider-man save the multiverse
now what by sanford green who's actually
a long time comics artist known for
minnie miles morales illustrations
there's also what looks like a
playstation controller because sony and
then floating everywhere are these
trading cards labeled teriyakimon must
be this universe analog for pokemon it's
even got a white and red pokeball
equivalent there and then when they're
both on the bed there's a framed photo
of miles with his uncle aaron aka the
prowler who died in the previous film
and then on a shelf it's an rc car of
the spidermobile a full-size version of
which showed up in the spider cave in
the 2018 film gwen has his wrist tech
just like the gizmo miguel o'hara used
to make an autonomous multiverse jump
you remember into the spider vs
post-credits scene revealed miguel
o'hara aka spider-man 2099 from earth
928 voiced by oscar isaac future mark
spector moon knight in the mcu miguel
comes from a future reality where he
works for the alchemix corporation he
has an ai named lila who we met at the
end of that movie nervous miles shoves
into his nightstand drawer a gundam wing
figurine a cup with a cowboy dinosaur
and one of those teriyakiman trading
cards along with his miles comic book
showing he's kind of embarrassed to have
a comic book of himself that he's
reading now on his shelf he has a
stuffed giraffe
just like kate bishop did in hawkeye and
like the stuffed giraffe and wanda's
nursery in one division and dane whitman
wanted to be a giraffe in eternals i
must be connected
but an actual easter egg here that
wooden moose on the shelf that is a
deliberate easter egg to lord miller's
other amazing animated film that came
out this year mitchell's versus the
machines that wood moose was the key
symbolic prop of that movie and when you
know the deeper meaning of it you're
gonna get emotional gwen flips through
mile's sketchbook and lands on a page
dedicated to her but you'll see on the
other side is a bus ticket hudson valley
explorer schenectady to brooklyn central
this was the bus that they took to and
from the alchemix lab in the 2018 film
that was the day where miles and gwen
really had their first sweet connection
you can also see how miles wrote his
shopping list down there milk eggs
tortillas avocados and again we are
partnering with short box to give away a
9.4 rated copy of ultimate fallout 4 the
first comic appearance of miles morales
the comic is currently valued around 700
dollars and that value is gonna
skyrocket if marvel listens to tom
holland and makes miles the next
live-action spider-man short boxed is
the easiest and safest way to buy and
sell graded comic books you can download
short box for free at ios and android
they have an incredible selection of
graded comics they have everything from
recent favorites to the first
appearances of the x-men or spider-man
some of the most valuable comics in the
world all orders are fully protected and
insured for both buyers and sellers
thousands of the most respected dealers
and collectors in the industry trust
short boxed and use it every day so to
enter this giveaway visit
shortboxed.com new rockstars to enter
and receive a promo code for 15 off your
first short boxed order again that's
shortboxed.com
new rockstars so miles joins gwen
through the multiverse and if you
remember in the 2018 film anytime a
character went through the multiverse it
was less structured more just like
floating through trans-dimensional space
but now it is super structured in this
tunnel of hexagonal rings which just
shows how this passageway is more
technologically controlled thanks to
miguel o'hara's innovations you'll
notice each ring brightens up as miles
passes through the ring each one likely
being its own exit ramp door to a
particular reality and miles drops
through one of these into the world of
spider-man india a metropolis called
mombatan which is a cross between mumbai
and manhattan reminds me a lot of san
fransokyo and big hero 6 there's a big
poster of this handsome looking dude
this actually could be the puppy tour of
this universe you'll notice the
animation here has softer edges the
colors kind of bleed into each other
just shows how the animators did quite a
bit of research into making this world
culturally distinct they also include
some indian music using tablas for
percussion
[Music]
and as miles bounces off of the stuff
here the comic bookie action words are
all in hindi in tamil the first
translates to pre
or the cars that are honking at him as
he's dropping past and then on a sign we
see the name kishore taylor and then
when miguel hits miles feck and then as
they both collide in the walkway right
after that da dam which is like a hindi
word for thud meanwhile the onlookers to
the right say in tamil the exclamation
and then lastly my favorite of all these
the hindi letters for the whip there's
not a hindi word for whip they just went
letter by letter to reconstruct it that
is awesome so miguel o'hara grabs miles
and on his multiverse wrist tech he
punches in nine two eight again that's
miguel o'hara's home reality number and
then back through more hexagonal rings
into what we assume is earth 928 taking
the form of a high-speed futuristic
freeway with you'll notice spanish
hollow text orbiting around it i think
that translates to please follow the
speed limit there's also the inverted
word alchemex on the tunnel suggesting
that the corporation may have designed
all the infrastructure of this world
you'll remember that is the same company
of olivia octavius that miles and peter
p parker were disrupting so this is the
same company that in the future of
miguel's reality he is connected to
you'll notice miguel's webbing glows as
he whips at miles in these jagged angle
lines just a cool way of making miguel's
elements more techy and distinct and
wired in contrast to miles's and then as
we transition into the title you'll
notice this miles spider logo rushes
through all these alterations just like
in the 2019 teaser in which the color
tones hinted to which alternate spiders
we could expect including the 1978
japanese spider-man takuya yamashiro as
well as spider-woman jessica drew who is
confirmed in this movie to be voiced by
issa rae we can also expect ben reilly
spider-man and cindy moon silk and
several others but then we get the title
spider-man across the spider-verse part
one so this movie's story line is still
a mystery but by already committing to a
multi-part event definitely recalls what
marvel studios initially pitched for
infinity war which was at first going to
be infinity war part 1 and infinity war
part 2 until they later renamed part 2
to be avengers in-game so if sony
animation has a similar structure in
mind for across the spider-verse we have
to ask what comic crossover event with
dark twists are they looking at adapting
i am wondering if we will see the
spider-geddon event in which
trans-dimensional energy vampires named
the inheritors are targeting each spider
hero of each dimension which requires
all these spider-man variants to
assemble into a vast army that includes
many of the incarnations we've been
talking about and dramatically kills a
number of them off also a reminder that
a live-action miles morales does exist
somewhere in the mcu based on aaron
davis's lines and homecoming i don't
want those weapons in this neighborhood
i got a nephew who live here yeah sorry
miles i'm not gonna make it and we
should not be surprised if sony might
use the multiversal crisis of spiderman
no way home and the multiversal crisis
from across the spiderverse to bring a
live-action miles in a live-action gwen
to the forefront of their franchise you
can support this channel by checking out
some of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to the rockstars
for more analysis and breakdowns of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you